thousands of Facebook members some as
young as 13 have reportedly been paid by
the social and media platform for their
data on their mobile phones but the app
used to do the job has been banned by
Apple after it was shown to have
violated privacy policies despite that
it's still available on a different
operating platform Android well Facebook
has been suggesting since 2016 for users
to install the Facebook research up it's
been paying them up to $20 a month to do
so when members were asked to give the
app almost unfettered access to their
personal information including private
messages on social media it was also
able to collect emails data on web
browsers and information about the
location no other users the social media
giant denies accusations that it was
spying on the teenagers online habits
it wasn't spying as all of the people
who signed up to participate went
through a queer onboarding process
asking for their permission less than 5%
of the people who chose to participate
in this market research program were
teens all of them was signed parental
consent forms or Facebook even asked
users to screenshot their Amazon orders
page parental consent was also said to
have been easily avoided in the entire
process journalist Derrick Rose says a
lot of people don't understand what
access to such data actually means I
think most people probably would find it
unethical because generally kids are not
going to understand what they're signing
up for most people don't know what they
sign up for whenever they sign the Terms
of Service and even if facebook is
saying I'm gonna give you 20 bucks or
whatever they're handing out I don't
think most people really understand how
their metadata and their digital
footprint tells a lot about who they are
as a person about where they go and just
about their entire life and I'm not sure
everybody really understands that when
you sign up for Facebook or any of these
social media companies or any website
really when you click I agree without
reading the Terms of Service and
particularly with apps on smartphones
most people don't understand what
they're giving companies permission to
do and especially when it relates to the
children according to a recent poll the
popularity of Facebook amongst American
teenagers has decreased by 20% since
2015 Derrick Rose again says the social
networking behemoth is going to great
lengths to retain its market share it is
obvious that Facebook is losing support
in favor among the younger generations
the younger Millennials and Generation Z
is some people call them where most of
them are using things like Instagram
which Facebook also owns and things like
snapchat and other platforms Facebook is
kind of seen like with the older thing
for the fact the parents and the
grandparents I think what Facebook is
trying to do is to buy up other
platforms like they bought Instagram
they bought whatsapp they're the the
company that runs Facebook Mark
Zuckerberg and his team I don't think
whether or not Facebook the social
network disappears I don't think they're
gonna go anywhere they're planning to
invest and make sure that they have
their hands and all the future social
networks
you